oh
[Musique]
raconter l'histoire commandeur oui ah
bon ah je vous raconte une histoire et
des pneus alors écoutez bien ça se passe
dans pays basque oui au pays basque on
savait qu'on joue à la pelote basque
avoriaz un vieux mécréants acquis plus
de mon âge je me cache il connaît bien
le curé par contre alors les décors et
les des six nations par dix on joue à la
pelote basque jeudi match devient la
magie est là mais c'est lorsqu'il dit
prêt à écouter je t'adore leur poste de
ben moi le seigneur je suis bien là bas
blesse parle pas alors le rendre ils
sont quotidiennes au curé tient la
réponse et des ouï-dire la iata qui
devrait poser le bon et le mauvais la
bonne habitude alors sois tranquille dit
au paradis on joue à la pelote basque l
homo vas-y tu commences à jouer demain
il allait mourir elle était mort de
massage ou devrais-je au paradis il
voulait aller au parlement ont pris à
l'île de ré se met à ronfler déjà dit
mais bien que toi lui et selon lui avait
récemment
fait déjà dit
de lui
mais ce qu'on retiendra c'est le rendez
vous est bien là ça va me faire de l'air
un peu arabe et sur les champs le
problème
est d'or le port il fallut faire un peu
de lait rien à côté moi encore une
histoire
parce que
t'es pas bon c'est sûr il va le faire
passer la nuit ici
ça y est on est réveillé vous fait trop
de bruit et je
pense ici
à ces pièces assez le remerciement que
jamais tadic à jour
[Rires]
[Musique]